we've all experienced the frustration
caused by congestive streets even though
sat-nav systems are supposed to alert
you to traffic jams Christian Bruggeman
says sometimes the systems are actually
part of the problem when there's a
detour around the traffic jam then every
vehicle with an intelligent navigation
system is alerted meaning every driver
that takes it ends up creating the next
traffic jam a new system is meant to
help prevent traffic congestion from
happening in the first place
Brueggemann has developed software that
gives each user an individual route as
soon as I get a suggested route that
route is simultaneously reserved for me
the software calculates how many cars
can travel a street at the same time if
one driver chooses a particular route
the system estimates when that car will
reach that street once the calculated
capacity is reached suggestions for
alternate routes are given to other
users his ending here on the left we see
the simulation with our cars and our
navigation system and on the right other
navigation systems you can clearly see
that with our reservation system
different routes are suggested to
different cars that optimally
distributes the traffic across the
infrastructure using the entire city
that means you reach your destination
much sooner on the right you can clearly
see that almost all vehicles are trying
to get through the main artery which
quickly leads to traffic congestion in
this area
it works well in the computer simulation
traffic flows up to 30% faster and even
twice as fast during rush hour but so
far not enough drivers use the app to
make it really effective so the idea is
for other manufacturers to integrate the
software into their sat-nav systems
you